lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
estar seguro de que estamos escogiendo
bien cuál es el vector normal al plano
si recibimos la ecuación para el plano
así que para entender vamos a empezar
con un plano por aquí
comencemos así que para esto voy a
dibujar aquí un plano pero recuerda que
su plan infinito solamente me estoy
tomando una parte del plano porque el
plano crece para todos lados y aquí voy
a tomarme al vector normal que va a ser
de la forma x y el vector canónico más b
por jota el otro vector canal y con más
c porque mis vectores canónicos este es
un evento normal y recuerda que este
vector normal cumple una propiedad muy
importante este vector normal es
ortogonal a todos los vectores que están
aquí en el plano y bueno a continuación
me voy a tomar un punto que le voy a
poner el punto x p ep y zp porque es un
punto que vive en el plano
xp de plano entonces es xp gps tape es
este punto de aquí y bueno puedes
dibujar unisex coordenadas voy a suponer
que éste
el eje de las setas este es el eje de la
siesta este de aquí es el eje de las 10
y por aquí está en mi eje de las x
déjame ponerlo mejor por aquí está en mi
eje de las x perfecto ya continuación
voy a dibujar un vector posición un
vector en su forma estándar que cumpla
una propiedad que su punto final es
decir el punto dando llega este vector
sea este punto x p gps tp este vector va
a ser muy importante por lo tanto quiero
que de una vez escribamos sus
componentes sus componentes van a ser xp
por el vector canónico y massieu p por
el vector canónico j
zp por el vector canónico k porque es un
vector en posición estándar y un vector
posición y bueno a este vector lo voy a
bautizar con el nombre de p 1 este
vector le voy a decir que el vector p 1
ip1 porque llega hasta el plano que
nosotros tenemos aquí
este es el bautizo de p 1 y bueno a
continuación también me voy a tomar a
otro punto en este plano otro punto y
voy a suponer que si este es el xp gps
tape a éste lo voy a llamar mucho más
fácil va a ser éste
aquí ya este punto le voy a llamar x
jay-z más fácil que el otro y este punto
equis y zeda también este del plano y
también voy a dibujar un vector posición
en su forma estándar que llegue hasta
este punto que está aquí
esto está punteado y fíjate que que ya
tengo a mi vector en mi vector tiene
como ecuación asociada pues sería x x y
maciej por jota más se está por acá xy
jz cab perfecto ya tengo aquí a mi otro
vector y bueno lo que quiero que veas a
continuación es algo muy importante es
algo indispensable para poder darle el
nombre a este plano porque si nosotros
tomamos la diferencia de estos dos
vectores entonces me estoy tomando un
vector que existe en este plano fíjate
bien yo tengo que tanto el vector p1
como el vector p ambos llegan a un punto
del plano por lo tanto si yo me tomo la
diferencia entre estos dos vectores que
va a ser este vector de azul que voy a
dibujar este vector de azul que voy a
dibujar existe en este plano vamos a
unir con la con cabeza y no voy a tomar
de aquí a acá este vector existe en este
plano que me estoy tomando aquí este
vector es muy importante porque date
cuenta en primer lugar es el vector p -
p 1 este vector llamado p - p 1 es la
diferencia de dos vectores y recuerda
que es el vector que tiene como punto
inicial el punto final de p 1 y como
punto final el punto final de p o en su
dado caso podremos decir cuál es el
vector que le falta a p 1 para llegar al
vector p y pues este es el vector p - p
1 ahora date cuenta que como va de 2
puntos que están en el plano este vector
existe en este plano y por lo tanto va a
cumplir que es ortogonal al vector
normal n recuerda que todos los vectores
que estaban en el plano todos eran
ortogonales a este vector normal y
recuerda que si dos vectores son
ortogonales entonces su producto punto
es igual a cero plazas eso vamos a
calcular quién es p - p uno ha puesto es
el vector x menos xp es decir la
diferencia de sus dos primeras
componentes que a su vez multiplican al
vector canónico
después me quedan más de siete tomándome
la diferencia que multiplica el vector
canónico j y por último más z menos zp
que multiplica el vector canónico acá y
bueno lo que yo sé es que como este
vector xxi en el plano y todos los
vectores que existían en mi plan no eran
ortogonales al vector n entonces
recuerda que en 'punto cualquier vector
en el plano es igual a cero porque son
ortogonales en este caso en el punto p -
p uno es igual a cero y bueno quien es
per - p uno podremos ya calcularlo esto
lo que daría el primer componente de n
por la primer componente de p - p 1 y me
quedara x menos a xp más la segunda
componente de n por la segunda
componente de términos p uno que me
queda b y btp y por último la tercera
componente de n que ese que multiplica a
su vez a la tercera componente del
vector p - p uno me va a quedar por zeta
- c por zp y recuerda que esto es un
escalar el producto punto me da de
resultados escalares por lo tanto todo
esto de aquí es una suma de
los reales y bien todo esto tiene que
ser igual a cero por lo tanto a
continuación lo que voy a hacer es pasar
del otro lado todo lo que tenga que ver
con el punto p por lo tanto me voy a
quedar con x con beijing y con cz de un
lado de la ecuación y del otro lado voy
a pasar los signos contrarios a todo lo
que tiene que ver con el punto p por lo
tanto me queda a x más bella más cz esto
es igual a quién
bueno pues voy a pasar todo el otro lado
entonces este de aquí se va a ir
positivo y me va a quedar es para tejer
y escribirlo por acá me va a quedar a xp
positivo entonces déjenme que agarrar el
color rojo para poner a xp entonces
tengo a xp positivo ya esto le tengo que
sumar b gp porque quiera negativo y
cuando pasa del otro lado se vuelve
positivo más bien p ya esto tengo que
agregar zp entonces más sé zp perfecto y
si te das cuenta aquí ya tengo el
ecuación de un plano recuerda cumplan
dos son todos los puntos de la forma x
z que cumplen esta ecuación que acabo de
encontrar aquí pero bueno esto ya lo
sabíamos esto ya lo habíamos visto en
vídeos pasados ahora lo que quiero ver
es lo contrario a esto dado un plano
como encuentro yo mi vector normal es
decir si les doy la ecuación de un plano
como puede un contrario el valor de este
vector normal aquel que me sirve para
definir este plano
entonces supongamos que les doy a x más
bella más cc está igual a d
esta es la ecuación de un plano que está
en r3 bueno mi pregunta es cómo
encontramos la ecuación o las
componentes de mi vector normal
asociados a este plano y bueno para esto
lo que quiero que veas es a lo que
acabamos de llegar esto que acabo de
escribir del lado derecho es justo esta
ecuación que tenemos aquí abajo a x más
bella más ez aunque sea de minúsculas y
del otro lado que teníamos teníamos todo
esto de aquí entonces déjame copiar
perfecto entonces lo voy a poner aquí
entonces lo único que hice fue escribir
esta ecuación al revés para que te des
cuenta de lo siguiente si ya tengo en la
ecuación de un plano entonces ésta tiene
que ser esta mayúscula esta minúscula
tiene que ser esta vez mayúscula y esta
minúscula tiene que ser esta semana y
todo esto que está aquí tiene que ser de
estos valores y lo sabemos porque son
números reales es una operación en los
nuevos reales y esto tiene que darnos el
valor de de y bueno todo esto para que
te lo estoy contando porque date cuenta
de una cosa si nosotros ya sabemos que a
minúscula es lo mismo que a mayúscula lo
mismo para ver lo mismo para c entonces
nuestro vector normal tenía como
componentes a b y c o si te das cuenta
nuestro vector normal lo podemos
escribir como a y más bj más seca que en
este caso va a ser a y más
bj más seca en mayúsculas y así de fácil
y así de sencillo podemos encontrar las
componentes o la ecuación de nuestro
vector normal es decir vamos a hablar un
ejemplo supongamos que yo te pongo
plano este plano de aquí menos 3 x
déjame ponerlo por acá bar que si nos
quepa menos 3x ya esto le voy a sumar la
raíz de dos por james ya esto más o
menos más más 7z vamos a ponerlo más 7z
igual a pi no sea cualquier número no
importa lo que quiero que veas es que ya
sabemos cuáles son los componentes de
nuestro vector normal nuestro vector
normal lo podemos escribir muy sencillo
porque solamente nos fijamos en qué
valores aunque coeficientes están al
lado de la x de la ley y de la zeta es
decir nuestro vector normal nos va a
quedar la forma menos 3 y más raíz de 2
por jota más 7 por acá así de fácil y
así de sencillo y date cuenta que no
importa qué número tengamos aquí podemos
tener brillo o cualquier otro número que
se nos ocurra porque al final este
número nos dice en donde cortamos al eje
de las setas podríamos tener por ejemplo
el valor de o el valor de 100 lo que sea
porque al final podemos prescindir de
este valor porque este valor solamente
nos dice cómo se traslada a nuestro
plano pero una inclinación del plano
sigue siendo la misma y cómo
sigue siendo la misma entonces el vector
normal sigue siendo ortogonal a todos
los planos de esta forma espero que esto
te haya sido bastante útil porque en el
siguiente vídeo voy a utilizar estos
mismos conceptos para definir la
distancia de un punto afuera de un plano
a ese mismo plano